rules not for me california congressman
eric swalwell the latest blue state dem
spotted hanging out maskless in mandate
free florida here to react is jimmy
fayla host of fox across america on fox
news radio and fox nation okay i i want
to get to this tweet because this is
amazing to me um this was uh he blasted
the gop for quote prolonging the
pandemic he said quote as we end 2021 in
a deadly pandemic you should know who
has prolonged it these guys republican
liars your vacation canceled your kids
back to virtual learning and back to
masks everywhere
for blame look no further than these
guys okay so obviously i don't think me
or anyone else cares who goes to you
know
the free state of florida but when
you're locking down and making all these
rules for these states like new york and
california
and then you
in the same breath are doing exactly
what you're hammering those states for
it's like it's tone not only tone deaf
but
it's a slap in the face
oh totally and you notice the key words
in his tweet are your vacation cancelled
not his vacation not aoc's vacation i
mean the only thing i'll give swalwell
credit for is at least he covered his
feet in the photo unlike aoc's dirtbag
boyfriend or fiance who is totally the
guy who trims his toenails next to you
on the plane that was disgusting but
this is why we have no buy-in when it
comes to public health initiatives
actually is none of the people pushing
them are following themselves and we all
know that
and i know it's a little early in the
morning but i will say that swalwell
getting caught in florida is still
better than the time he got caught in a
chinese spy
i was going to go there in a different
way but it underscores the overall
gaslighting that this guy loves to do i
mean actually read the tweet you
remember when the whole fang fang you
know sleeping with a chinese spy thing
happened he blamed it on republicans now
he's blaming all the things that he and
the democrats are doing wrong on
republicans if there was a gaslighting
hall of fame jimmy fella would swallow
be its most deserving member sort of
like the tom brady of it
oh totally you realize now in this
moment
the tom brady of it i don't know if he
deflated any of his tweets along the way
in his gas lighting so i don't want to
quite make him tom brady but no it is
amazing todd because that's totally what
they're doing now is they're using this
as a culture war issue they know they
don't have solutions to this pandemic
joe biden said when he was running
anybody who presided over as many deaths
as donald trump shouldn't be president
well joe biden has presided over more
deaths than donald trump despite
inheriting three vaccines okay and the
problem is what they've pivoted to now
is not public health it's culture war
it's blaming the other guys that's what
they're down to now oh we would have
solved it but you know the other guys
who aren't taking the vaccine
i'm vaccinated you're vaccinated
vaccinated
people are still getting the virus
that's the ridiculous part of this whole
thing but they don't have an answer to
that so they're just making it sound
like well what else can you do but head
down to florida this is embarrassing i'm
really living in the death of shame man
they're floundering right now we've got
about 45 seconds left cdc roasted for
new covid guidance after 180 whiplash
from previous rules jimmy as a father
what would happen if you gave your kid
mixed signals like this
yeah that
it's insane nobody can follow this i'm
pretty sure at this point they just
retweeted the lyrics from the hokey
pokey you put your right leg in you put
your right leg out nobody's following
this you know what it reminds me of
really quick really quick todd it
reminds me of that old uh looney tunes
episode where they're selling insurance
and you'll get a million dollars if you
get a black guy on the fourth of july
caused by a stampede of wild elephants
followed by one baby zebra there's way
too much fine print is what i'm trying
to say cdc and we should replace
whoever's in charge of their messaging
with someone who's easier to understand
like the dad from the peanuts cartoons
right i feel like the cdc has been about
as understandable with the guidance as a
rubik's cube throughout this whole thing
and it just keeps getting worse okay
jimmy fallon thanks so much for being
with us this morning we appreciate it